welcome back to new rock stars it's me
mt and batman unburied is one of the
dopest narrative podcasts on spotify
right now and this video is sponsored by
spotify so we can break down the super
crazy and disturbing episode 2 of this
addicting listen of a superhero show on
spotify so let's go ahead and dive into
it by beautiful nerd babies we start off
the episode with winston duke bruce
wayne having a sit down with his
psychotherapist dr hunter played by john
ruiz davies who tries to get into his
mind while bruce wayne being the guarded
man that he is just straight up outright
resists and refuses very much reflecting
just how well mentally trained the
psyche of this version of bruce wayne is
against outside influences as the batman
in the comics is of course famous for
his ability to resist all types of
interrogation techniques and even
psychic mental manipulations and i
thought it was a nice touch for dr
hunter to open up the episode with i'm
going to turn the lights on now
asthmatically we all know that bruce
wayne is a creature of the dark who
shuns the light so having this dr hunter
start off by opening the lights
symbolizes that bruce wayne is about to
be put into an uncomfortable situation
with dr hunter's therapeutic
interrogation that sought to shine a
light on his subconscious something that
bruce would directly tell hunter not to
do a little bit later on and i also
thought that one of dr hunter's first
questions that he asked bruce is really
quite intriguing here let's talk about
fear
before this incident when was the last
time you remember being afraid
maybe
i don't know a few years ago
you haven't felt true fear in years
unless you count nightmares which is yet
another accurate characterization of
bruce wayne is extremely concerning
inability to fear fear and face danger
with a calm mind and body which is of
course something that was hinted at at
the very first episode of batman
unburied when his father thomas saw just
how unaffected bruce was about being
nearly harvested by the harvester which
is you know it's kind of just
cold-blooded hold up your hand
you are seriously wounded you just woke
up you ripped to the gills on payment
and you're angry with me and look at
that
your hands as steady as a goddamn rock
last night a serial murderer attacked
you in the morgue
and i bet your heart rate barely went
above resting but bruce does feel fear
during nightmares though and we
definitely have gotten a hint of those
lingering nightmares as they have
started to bleed into reality through
batman on barry's amazing sound design
with of course that weird bat moment at
the end of the episode where bruce is
hearing these bad sounds that kell can't
hear sort of signaling those nightmares
bleeding into reality bruce are you okay
[Music]
what
what
[Music]
bruce are you okay
you don't hear that what's wrong with
you gross please
and when hunter says perhaps he feels a
kinship with you
some might call you a methodical
obsessive man it felt so much in line
with matt reeves new batman universe on
the big screen with the riddler becoming
obsessed with batman's obsessive love of
vengeance however when hunter said you
are very protective about what's inside
your mind aren't you
there's nothing in there that would
interest you trust me
i disagree it made my ears perk up
because just the way that hunter says oh
i disagree makes me feel like he could
potentially have a sketchy mo for
himself possibly an attempt to get some
sneaky family intel on the wanes for his
own purposes who knows but i feel like
he wants a little bit more here and i
also found it interesting how dr hunter
mentions that bruce wayne is not a
detective and he's supposed to be this
doctor and i was like ah i don't think
you've been a batman comic girlfriend
because uh bruce wayne is the world's
greatest detective
and as the scene transitions we get the
sweet sounds of black canaries ashes on
sunday band which is mentioned by the
gotham radio dj his ashes on sunday with
their number one hit
in gotham's park row also gets a
reference in this episode when bruce is
recalling the tragedy of elliot bonham
one of the five harvester victims who
had their organs sent to bruce wayne's
house this fixed name
is elliot bona
lives on park row with his two kids park
row or more popularly known as crime
alley is of course the location of
thomas and martha wayne's deaths in the
dc comics but apparently not in this
universe because they're still walking
around talking to their son who they
love very much and when thomas wayne
talks about amygdalotomies he's actually
referring to the surgical removal of the
amygdala from the human brain which is
apparently something that some doctors
have done in the past as a last resort
for patients who struggle with overly
violent outbursts or you know just
general hyper excitability but one of
the biggest side effects of this type of
procedure is that people who have
undergone it usually have some trouble
with facial recognition afterwards as
there are special cells within the
amygdala that aid with helping your
brain recognize the people that you know
as well as what their facial expressions
even mean when they do stuff like smile
frown or you know express disgust and
whatnot so i'm interested to see if how
if at all this could potentially factor
into this audio drama series but also
another negative thing about
amygdalotomies is that a lot of patients
actually become more violent and
sometimes even develop schizophrenia
with some people even describing a life
without an amygdala as a life of hell so
needless to say it's actually a super
controversial procedure as you know a
lot of people just need their amygdalas
because amygdalas are great having
feelings are great
but as bruce points out the harvester
seems to only be removing the amygdala
from his victims after he's tortured
them and had their organs removed which
bruce notes is the killer's way of
potentially removing fear from the
bodies of his victims which is a really
interesting thing considering his whole
jesus christ theme that he's trying to
go for from last episode and when the
father and son pair discover a piece of
foreign black substance within one of
the harvester's victims bruce notes that
what he found was a piece of obsidian a
black piece of super sharp volcanic
glass that surgeons have used for
centuries even to this day specifically
because of obsidian's ability to cut
objects and skin significantly more
efficiently than steel scalpels can and
obsidian scalpels can even cause skin
scarring after surgery to be minimal and
for the overall healing of the skin to
be just way faster after surgery it's
just a lot more efficient of a scalpel
but speaking of the skin a really
intriguing moment between thomas and
bruce happens when bruce touches his
father's hand your hands
let me see it
have you had your circulation checked
your hands are freezing
i'm afraid i'm not as used to being done
in this dungeon as you are
thomas's reaction is quite interesting
to me considering how historically in
the comics thomas and martha wayne are
of course
dead so you know usually their skin
would be cold during this adult bruce
wayne stage of his life because you know
that's just how dead people's skins are
when they've been dead for about you
know 18 to 20 years
usually you don't have skin at that
point anyway um and considering how
bruce's reaction to his mother dropping
her pearl necklace last episode
accompanied by the sounds of all these
screeching bats i don't know it's
starting to feel to me that this bruce
wayne might be haunted by the spirits of
his dead parents while he is trying to
solve this case possibly even
hallucinating them whenever he feels
like he needs it the most like how his
father just helped him with the surprise
autopsy that he had to do on his spare
time but another interesting thing to
mention here is that during bruce
wayne's phone call with kell to help him
into that medical building at gotham
university kel mentions that the
building closes at 6 00 pm on sundays
which is interesting considering how
that radio host earlier on in the
episode was playing that black canary
band ashes on sunday and since bruce
wayne is dealing with a lot of dead
people on a sunday afternoon it sort of
makes that ashes on sunday reference a
really nice thematic piece of
foreshadowing for this episode i'm
standing outside the medical building at
gotham u right now
and
it's locked
i really need to get inside
oh yeah they lock the whole place up at
six on sundays and when kell finally
arrives we learn that both thomas wayne
and kell's own father both attended
gotham state university and that kel's
father was actually a chemist which
feels very much in line with another
famous face from gotham university in
the comics that of jonathan crane also
known as the scarecrow who actually
first becomes imprisoned in arkham
asylum after murdering the people who
were responsible for getting him fired
from his job at gotham university for
the minor offense of firing your gun in
class to induce fear i mean why would
you fire somebody because of that but
that was mostly because crane loved to
do a lot of weird experimentations with
fear on campus even developing the
prototype for what would eventually
become his famous fear toxin on this
very campus so it would be interesting
to learn if either of their fathers have
any connection to the villain scarecrow
in their past as these episodes continue
and when bruce and kell head up to the
parking garage to meet up with this
mysterious cornelius stark figure that
security man tony points them to they
discover an audio recording of the
harvester feasting on the organs of his
victims after begging someone to find
him only after he is complete and this
sort of sounds especially like the mo of
one cornelius jerk from the dc comics
who would feast on the flesh of his
victims but only after their bodies
filled them up with the tasty fear
chemicals that he thought would sustain
them like some type of murder gatorade
but needless to say this episode was
insane and i loved every second of it
and i cannot wait to listen to more so
you go on over to spotify right now and
listen to the batman unburied podcast it
is amazing and if they got a couple
episodes right now and you will have a
good time on your drive to work but
anyways thank you guys so much for
watching this video you can follow me at
mastertainment on twitter but you can
also follow new rockstars wherever we
are on social media make sure you hit
that notification bell so you get
notifications every time we upload a
video but anyway thank you guys so much
for watching i love you guys so much and
i'll see you guys later goodbye
you